[Music]  hey crew what isn't this beautiful and  what is that glorious aroma i think it's  all the bodies no no no it's wonderful i  remember when we first arrived here  just a bunch of foolish kids really  what did i tell you  well you said we were going on a  vacation to indigaria it was beautiful  the sunrise you mentioned nothing about  it spinning off into chaos and utter  pain pain  [Applause]  look at this guy sleeping on the job are  we lazy bones he's dead  i told you listen to me and you have got  to get us out of here remember when you  told us that this was going to be a safe  vacation i said are you certain you said  oh yeah 100  out of a thousand  percent  there's a maniac who seeks to end us all  and putting together the greatest team  ever are you packed  yes  [Applause]  guardians  yes they are they also scream quite a  lot  you said this would be a relaxing  holiday  [Music]  i said it was going to be like a  relaxing holiday  [Music]  you